[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In this
video, you will learn
how to use Cloud Logging to
determine what caused a Google
Compute Engine instance to
unexpectedly reboot or shut
down.
With a few exceptions,
most activities
related to a virtual
machine's lifecycle
are automatically
added to Cloud Logging
in the form of an audit log.
Audit logs are easiest
way to get insights
about a VM's activities.
When a VM reboots or
shuts down unexpectedly,
try doing the following.
Select the VM that
shut down or rebooted.
In this example, the VM named My
Instance shut down and rebooted
unexpectedly several times
in the last seven days.
On the log section of
the VM details page,
click Cloud Logging.
Cloud Logging opens with
a pre-built query that
filters for the instance ID.
Narrow down your data set
using additional filters.
Select the log
name dropdown menu
and look for cloud audit
category, or search for audit.
Select the activity
and system event logs.
Activity logs describe
changes made to GCP resources,
such as compute instances.
System event logs
describe events
generated by Google systems.
Narrow down the search to
an approximate timeframe
when the VM reboot or
termination occurred.
In this example, we know the
shutdown occurred sometime
in the last seven days.
Each cloud audit log entry
displays a compute instance's
label that describes
the method associated
with a particular
instance and which
principal, otherwise known
as a user or service account,
was associated with that method.
The following log
entries are activities.
Audited operations that cannot
be executed instantly will run
asynchronously, and therefore
may appear twice in the Cloud
Logging results.
The first entry represents
the request itself,
and the second entry represents
the outcome of the request,
such as a success
or an error message.
For example, this log entry
illustrates that, on April 4,
a stop instance method
was issued to My Instance
by the principal
user@example.com.
Then, on April 7, a
reset instance method
was issued to the same
instance by the service account
schedulerbot@example.com.
The following log entries
are system events.
System events will always
show system@google.com
listed as the principal
because these events aren't
driven by direct user action.
This log entry illustrates
that, on April 8,
My Instance was shut down
by the operating system.
Note that operating system
reboots are not tracked
by the cloud audit logs.
If the audit logs
do not adequately
explain why an
instance was rebooted,
then it was most likely caused
by an operating system reboot.
In that case, consider
investigating the operating
system logs for further clues.
Finally, these two log
entries logged on April 9
indicate that the machine was
shut down due to a host error
and was automatically restarted.
Occasionally, there
might be problems
with the physical machine
that hosts the VM.
This is referred
to as a host error
and is indicated by the
compute.instances.hostError
method, which means that
the VM was terminated.
Some examples of events
that might cause host errors
are physical
hardware malfunctions
or a natural
disaster that impacts
the location of the
Google Cloud data center.
After a host error, the VM is
set to restart automatically,
which is indicated by
the compute.instance
s.automaticRestart method.
To protect your
applications and services
from these potentially
disruptive system events,
Google has shared several
best practices that
explain how you can design
robust systems in Google
Cloud, use patterns for
scalable, resilient apps,
and encourages using
managed instance groups
when appropriate.
In addition, Compute Engine
also offers live migration
to keep your instances running
during a maintenance event.
There are two methods which
might appear after a Compute
Engine maintenance event.
The compute.instance
s.migrateOnHostMaintenance
method indicates that
the Compute Engine
used a live migration
to keep your VM running
during a maintenance event.
Compute Engine live migrates
your running instances
to another host
in the same zone,
instead of requiring
your VMs to be rebooted.
This allows Google to
perform maintenance
that is integral to keeping
infrastructure protected
and reliable without
interrupting any of your VMs.
Live migrations are
enabled by default,
except for VMs with GPUs.
But this can be disabled
under the availability policy
of the particular instance.
The compute.instance
s.terminateOnHostMaintenance
method indicates that a live
migration was disabled or is
not supported on
that particular VM,
so the VM was terminated
during the maintenance event.
For more information on how
to troubleshoot VM shutdowns
or reboots and a list of
other common methods found
in Cloud Logging, check out
the official troubleshooting
documentation with the link
below in the description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]